is there anything worse than your
favorite TV show coming to an end well
there is actually when that shows who
had a lot of life in it and should never
have been canceled in the first place
it's one thing when a show reaches the
end of its natural life cycle and rides
off into the sunset but it's another
when that show was murdered by the
network I have an idea he is a look at
five TV cancellations that were a
mistake bloodline with an all-star cast
including Kyle Chandler [ __ ] Spacek and
a Linda Cardellini bloodline was touted
as the next big prestige series from
Netflix instead a got a pink slip after
just three seasons despite increasing
buzz including an Emmy win and Golden
Globe nomination for co-star Ben
Mendelsohn since Netflix rarely releases
any of their viewership statistics it's
impossible to know how many fans the
show actually has but rumors claim the
series was young too the financial
dispute between Netflix and Sony which
produced the series whatever the reason
it's too bad this bloodline has gone
extinct Marvel's agent Carter while
Marvel movies have been hitting on all
cylinders their TV shows have had a
spotty record that's what makes it even
more tragic that arguably their best
show yet Marvel's agent Carter was
cancelled after just two seasons ending
on a cliffhanger that may never be
resolved
I'm leaving just a mute second who shot
him is he okay
what's happening we may never know and
the show's untimely demise was
especially galling considering the
series was not just a critical darling
but vital to building the backstory of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe giving
fans a look at all the events that
shapes the superhero world from the end
of World War 2 through the debut of iron
man with decades of stories still untold
let's hope Marvel gives agent Carter
another chance of sometime in the future
good girls revolt quick history lesson
back in 1983 a new sitcom called Cheers
was among the lowest rated series on
television rather than cancel it though
NBC decided to give us a chance to build
a fan base resulting in one of the most
beloved runs and television history she
has arrived because it was given more
time to mature but no such opportunity
was given
the Amazon series good girls revolt
which was amazingly canceled just six
weeks after the first season debuted in
October 2016 far too soon for the
streaming service to know whether or not
a story about women seeking equal rights
in the 60s could catch on with viewers I
want the other girls my filing an equal
employment claim it's illegal for them
not to let us write we want the policy
change
so why the quick hook according to
reports Amazon Studios chief Roy price
personally dislikes the show even though
it apparently was popular with viewers
he gets a vote fans down the nightly
show when Stephen Colbert left his
Comedy Central hit the Colbert Report in
2015 veteran daily show contributor
Larry Wilmore took over the timeslot
with his own spin on the events of the
day with a nightly show and his take on
things was one many fans felt was long
overdue and hearing from you guys has
really been incredible
even you at one more blow sick sick sick
unfortunately will Moore's dry humor and
invasive look at political and social
issues didn't draw high enough ratings
to satisfy the network the good news is
Wilmore has since signed a development
deal with ABC but in today's divisive
political climate
his voice has sorely missed brain dead
the science fiction horror political
satire comedy was probably a bit of a
risk for CBS but it had a nice pedigree
going for it it was created by Michelle
and Robert King creators of CBS's
long-running legal drama The Good Wife
the offbeat premise a documentary
filmmaker from a prominent family goes
to work for her senator brother in
Washington DC and discovers that
parasitic alien bugs have taken over the
minds of the US government's top leaders
the show was cancelled because of low
ratings probably because people are just
getting tired of reality television
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know your love scene
[Applause]
[Music]